[Music]
moral outrage is a very powerful emotion
that motivates us to shame and punish
people who have broken some social rule
who have harmed us or someone we care
about in some way and there are many
benefits of moral outrage but there are
also many costs so the benefits can fall
into two broad categories the first
category of benefit is social benefits
so when we express outrage about some
kind of wrongdoing that teaches others
that that kind of behavior is not going
to be tolerated and it can motivate
other people to behave morally so that
they can avoid getting shamed or
punished for breaking the rules the
other kind of benefit that moral outrage
brings about is personal moral outrage
broadcasts to the rest of your social
group that you are the kind of person
who's not likely to break the rules so
these two benefits of expressing outrage
have to be balanced against the costs of
outrage
so expressing outrage carries some risks
particularly in the day to day world if
you approach a stranger on the street
let's say for littering
there's a chance they might retaliate
against you there's a chance that they
could physically aggress against you we
saw a really tragic case of the huge
possible costs of expressing moral norms
and trying to regulate bad behavior
earlier this year in Portland when a
couple of people really brave people
lost their lives for trying to rein in
someone who is expressing racist
comments on a on a commuter train in
Portland so it can be risky to express
outrage it can be uncomfortable
stressful telling somebody to their face
that they've done something wrong is
just awkward sometimes so when we are
expressing outrage we really have to
weigh these costs against the benefits
and evolution has equipped us
a really fine-tuned calculus for making
these kinds of decisions in
interpersonal and face-to-face
interactions if moral outrage is a fire
the internet is like gasoline so when we
think about the costs and benefits of
expressing outrage what social media
does is it turns down all the costs and
dials up the benefits so expressing
outrage on social media is way easier
than expressing it offline it's less
costly you can do it with the click of a
button you can join a large crowd so
hiding amongst a lot of other people
really takes down the riskiness of
expressing outrage towards a person
who's who's broken some norm and of
course it it dials up the benefits
you're getting social feedback likes
from your friends retweets shares and
the audience of course is so much bigger
on social media than it is offline so
the reputational benefits of expressing
outrage are massively bigger when you
take it online
so moral outrage is really interesting
because of its reputational benefits and
it can be contrasted with cyberbullying
for example both are aggressive kinds of
behaviors but the one expresses that you
are a morally good person and the other
has rather the opposite effect so
research on cyberbullying seems to
suggest that anonymity that's often
found online increases cyberbullying but
there are fewer studies on this but it
seems like the opposite occurs in the
case of moral outrage expression online
so there is one recent study that looked
at expressions of outrage in an online
political forum in Germany and in this
study they they looked at the effects of
being anonymous versus identified on how
aggressive the language was in these
posts that had to do with social
policies
and they actually found that that people
were were expressing more outrage about
these moral political issues when they
were not anonymous so that seems to
contrast with what what is typically
seen for cyberbullying
[Music]
you